devenu ridicule cette nouvelle qui n'a
pas passé chez bien des musulmans
provocatrice parce que je considère que
ça s'est fait de façon abusive et
arbitraire sans aucune concertation et
consultation des de la communauté
musulmane parce que c'est la première
concernée l'interdiction par le
gouvernement du Québec d'aménager des
lieux de prière dans les écoles
primaires et secondaires publics
n'aurait pu arriver à un pire moment
pour nous en plein mois de Ramadan qui
est à moi sacré pour pour les musulmans
ils sont
dans leur prière dans leur recueillement
dans les mosquées etc et on nous vient
avec cette cette nouvelle donc ça crée
beaucoup de mots dans notre communauté
dans une lettre publié jeudi plusieurs
leaders musulmans du Québec croient que
le ministre de l'Éducation Bernard
drinville fait fausse route faut que le
ministre révise ses cours de laïcité
parce que laïcité ne veut pas dire la
négation des religions mais plutôt
de faire en sorte de créer une une
ambiance de vivre ensemble leur
regroupement passe maintenant à se
tourner vers les tribunaux pour faire
valoir ses droits on va étudier le
dossier de point de vue juridique si on
a des droits ici nous nous avocats nous
nous conseille d'aller en avant on va on
va y aller en avant et c'est la
responsabilité des élus aussi
spécialiste du droit à constitutionnel
croient qu'une éventuelle cause serait
complexe dès qu'on met une un concept
plus large en fait dans un texte de
l'importance de la Charte québécoise
d'ailleurs il y a plusieurs personnes
les gens étaient là qui ont critiqué la
modification à la majorité simple de la
Charte québécoise le via la loi 21 mais
la laïcité dans un texte fondamental
comme la charge te québécoise ben
écoutez un concept large comme celui-là
c'est toujours à travers
l'interprétation coparka qu'on est
capable de circonscrire sa portée du
côté politique nous avons tenté
d'obtenir un commentaire de la part du
ministre Drainville au sujet de la
lettre mais notre demande a été refusé
ici Philippe Radio-Canada Québec